depuis quelques années vous pouvez
l'applaudir régulièrement au théâtre de
50 en Yvelines où il est en résidence il
prépare actuellement une version concert
de Cosy van tout et de Mozart qu'il
présentera les 29 et 30 mars au Théâtre
de 50 ans en Yvelines ceci avant d'être
en juin avec 250 enfants pour un grand
programme Mozart et d'être en 2014 avec
un opéra pour enfants qu'il va créer au
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
voici David Stern dans le kiosque
on l'a pas encore travaillé alors on
fait nos répétitions au mois de mars
pour avoir nos concerts à la fin du mois
avec nous jeunes chanteurs bien sûr et
mes collègues de l'orchestre d'opelafo
et peut-être l'opéra le plus
psychologique le plus
subtil de tous les grands opéras de
Mozart qu'il avait écrit avec Daponte
pour le livre comme livraison
c'est on parle toujours de
l'ENA certificaro Don Giovanni et Così
fan toutes dans le même
phrase à cause de cette collaboration
avec avec la ponte et très souvent cosy
et le peut-être on peut dire la sœur un
peu un peu moins un peu oubliée à plutôt
que les deux autres parce que c'est un
opéra qui a moins de tubes mais beaucoup
plus d'ensemble c'est un opéra
d'ensemble c'est
léger mais c'est aussi parfois très
sérieux
des adolescents qui deviennent des
jeunes adultes et qui comprennent que
l'amour est
toujours
la Boudia toujours la beauté de l'amour
mais il y a aussi la complexité de la
nature humaine
et là
bien que c'est toujours dans un contexte
très drôle et très 18ème siècle les
termes sont très actuels et il y a la
finalité la vraie amour à la séduction
alors on fait une vente bien son concert
mais nos amis du public de Saint-Quentin
nous connaissent déjà et quand on fait
quand on peut la fois qu'on fait une
version concert on fait toujours avec
des allers-retours avec des gags avec
quelque chose qui anime on n'aime pas
dire qu'en version concertante sèche
parfois ça dégage tellement que il y a
des membres du 8 qui disent on a même
pas besoin d'une mise en scène moi
j'adore les mises en scène mais là je
peux me concentrer sur les effets
musicaux
mais l'idée c'est de commencer
l'aventure de Cosy parce que l'année
suivante en 2014 on va faire une version
de cosy qui est inconnue parce qu'on
crée
un opéra moderne c'est-à-dire on va
faire un sorte plus prélude de Cosy
composé par Nicolas Bacri avec le livret
de Eric Emmanuel Schmitt qui se
réconcerait une histoire qui ou prédate
le cosy qu'on connaît c'est-à-dire que
tous les quatre amants sont des très
jeunes
garçons et filles qui commencent à ce
connaître et le vrai enjeu c'est entre
Donald fanzo Despin comme ce sont des
enfants c'est cosy fanchuli parce que
fanchool est en italien ce sont des
enfants cosy fan tout et donc cosy ça
sera une
heure pour public c'est à dire que c'est
assez aussi pour les enfants que pour
les parents
l'équipe 51 Yvelines ne devait demander
de faire une soirée avec des jeunes pour
chanter du Mozart en a choisi des airs
au lieu des grands cœur on a choisi des
airs connus que les enfants vont
apprendre et vont chanter en cœur c'est
mon équipe qui a déjà commencé à
travailler avec eux depuis des mois à
rentrer dans les classes à travailler
avec avec les jeunes sur le texte sur le
contexte l'histoire de chaque heure et
puis le soir même on aura tout le monde
sur scène avec une grande partie de
l'orchestre d'opéra rock ce projet nous
permet de commencer à travailler avec
ces jeunes qu'on va revoir l'année
prochaine sur Così fan
si on commence très en amont et on
travaille toujours avec les mêmes alors
il y a quelque chose qui se passe entre
nous et les chanteurs les jeunes entre
les jeunes eux-mêmes avec cette
autodiscipline d'être sur scène alors il
y a quelque chose qui marche depuis les
années qu'on est à Saint-Quentin on fait
tellement de travail avec les jeunes
c'est toujours un plaisir pour moi pour
mon équipe pour mes chanteurs et c'est
un travail qu'on va continuer à creuser
à l'avenir
et il est l'heure de retrouver un
nouveau sujet de la rédaction
patchouli cannelle rose coriandre au
temps d'odeur que nos petits nez en
herbe vont s'amuser à reconnaître
l'Osmothèque de Versailles lieu unique
au monde de conservation du parfum
propose pendant les vacances un atelier
pour enfants de découverte des senteurs
l'idée pour les enfants c'est
d'apprendre deux trois deux trois idées
sur la parfumerie de comprendre un petit
peu d'où d'où viennent les matières
premières de la parfumerie qu'elles
peuvent en fait eux-mêmes sentir dans la
nature découvrir que la fleur d'oranger
sang que la rosente la lavande etc et
puis aussi pour eux faire un exercice
vraiment ludique où ils essaient de
trouver de retrouver l'odeur qui va avec
la petite image qui leur est présentée
un programme ludique et participatif où
chaque enfant peut s'initier au monde
des senteurs en découvrant leur histoire
et en faisant travailler son nez et sa
mémoire olfactive ce que j'aime bien
c'est sentir les odeurs et en découvrir
j'ai découvert celle du muguet
celle de l'estragon et celle de la fleur
d'oranger pour maintenir en éveil
l'odorat des enfants rien de tel que de
susciter leur intérêt et leur curiosité
un exercice que certains pratiquent déjà
au quotidien car c'est notre Dora et ben
on peut reconnaître les différents pas
les différents goûts est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que tu faisais déjà à la
maison ou quand tu te promènes dehors je
faisais souvent l'atelier d'une durée
d'une heure trente est accessible aux
enfants
âgés de 8 à 11 ans en dehors des
vacances scolaires les petits nez
peuvent aussi se retrouver les mercredis
mais encore quelques dates à noter avant
de regarder votre série préférée et
découvrir enfin qui est vraiment Pamela
Jean-Pierre Vincent proposera ici
ayantent les 20 et 21 mars au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines tandis que
même date les 20 et 21 mars dambées sera
l'occasion d'écouter un concert narratif
sous casque à la ferme de Bel et ben à
Guyancourt le 22 mars le chorégraphe au
fush schester présentera Uprising the
art of note looking back au prisme à
Élancourt et les 22 23 mars Judith
Depaule proposera son fameux diptyque
corps de femme le marteau le ballon
ovale au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affichent et cette
semaine du 12 au 18 mars vous pouvez
gagner 5 fois deux places pour Richard
Galliano au prisme et également cinq
fois deux places pour le concert jeune
public d'Alain Schneider à l'estaminet
alors bon spectacle à tous et à bientôt
le cache c'est de la balle